The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good, we're going
to take a detour today into
the realm of algorithms.
So when you're trying to make
code go fast, of course,
there's no holds barred.
You can use whatever you
need to in order
to make it go fast.
Today we're going to talk
a little bit in a more
principled way about the
memory hierarchy.
And to do that we're going to
introduce what we call the
ideal-cache model.
So as you know most caches are
hacked together to try to
provide something that will
cache well while still making
it easy to build and
fast to build.
The ideal-cache model
is a pretty nice
beast if we had them.
It's got a two-level
hierarchy.
It's got a cache that has m
bytes that are organized in to
b byte cache-lines.
So each block is b bytes.
And it's fully associative.
So you recall, that means
that any line can
go anywhere in cache.
And probably the most impressive
aspect of an
ideal-cache is that
it has an optimal
omniscient replacement algorithm.
So what it does, is it figures
out when it needs to kick
something out of cache, it says,
what is the absolutely
best thing you could possibly
kick out of cache.
And it does that one.
Looking into the future
if need be.
It says, oh is this going
to be accessed
a lot in the future?
I think I'll keep this one.
Let's throw out this one.
I know it's never going
to be used again.
So it has that omniscient
character to it.
The performance measures we're
going to look at in this
model, the first one is
what we call the work.
And that's just the ordinary
serial running time if you
just ran the code on one
processor and counted up
essentially how many processor
instructions you would do.
That's essentially the work.
The second measure, which is
the one that's much more
interesting, is cache misses.
So the work has to do
with the processor.
The cache misses has to do with
what moves between these
two levels of memory.
So in this case, what we're
interested in doing is, how
often do I try to access
something.
It's not in the cache.
I have to go to main memory and
bring it back into cache.
And so that's what we'll be
counting in this model.
So it's reasonable to ask how
reasonable ideal caches are.
In particular the assumption
of omniscient replacement,
that's pretty powerful stuff.
Well it turns out there's a
great lemma due to Slater and
Tarjan that says essentially
the following.
Suppose that you have an
algorithm that incurs q cache
misses on an ideal
cache of size n.
So you ran the algorithm on
your machine, you had a
cache of size n.
Then, if instead of having an
ideal cache, you have a fully
associative cache of size two
m and use the least recently
used replacement policy.
So you always, whenever you're
kicking something out of
cache, you kick out the thing
that has been touched the
longest ago in the past.
Then it incurs at most
2Q cache misses.
So what that says is that LRU is
to with it constant factors
essentially the same
as optimal.
Really quite a remarkable
result.
Who's taking 6046?
You've just seen this, right?
Yeah, OK.
Just seen this result in 6046.
See, I do talk to my colleagues
occasionally.
So then something about
how this is proved.
And what's important here is
that really it just says, OK,
Yeah you could dither on the
constants, but basically
whether you choose LRU or choose
ideal cache with the
omniscient replacement,
asymptotically you're not
going to be off at all.
So for most asymptotic analyses,
you can assume
optimal or LRU replacement
as convenient.
And the typical way that you
do convenience is if you're
looking at upper bounds.
So you're trying to show that
a particular algorithm is
good, then what you do is you
assume optimal replacement.
If you're trying to show that
some algorithm is bad, then
what you do is assume that it's
LRU to get a lower bound.
Because then you can reason
more easily about what's
actually in memory.
Because you just say, oh we'll
just keep the least
recently used one.
So you tend to use the two for
upper bounds and lower bounds.
Now, the way this relates
to software
engineering is as follows.
If you're developing a really
fast algorithm, it's going to
start from a theoretically
sound algorithm.
And from that then you have
to engineer for detailed
performance.
So you have to take into account
things like real
caches are not fully
associative.
That loads and stores, for
example, have different cost
with respect to bandwidth
and latency.
So whether you miss some a
load or miss on a store,
there's a different impact.
But these are all the tuning.
And as you know, those constant
factors can sometimes
add up to dramatic numbers,
orders of magnitude.
And so it's important to do
that software engineering.
But starting from a good
theoretical basis means that
you actually have an algorithm
that is going to work well
across a large variety
of real situations.
Now, there's one other
assumption we tend to make
when we're dealing with ideal
caches, and that's called the
tall-cache assumption.
So what the tall-cache
assumption says, is that I you
have at least as many lines of
cache, essentially, in your
cache, as you have bytes
in the line.
So it says the cache is tall.
In other words, this dimension
here is bigger than this
dimension here.
And in particular, you want that
to be true for where we
have some constant here of slop
that we can throw in.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Does that
[INAUDIBLE]
associatively make the
cache shorter here.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so this
is basically assuming
everything is ideal.
We're going to go back.
When you engineer things, you
have to deal with the fact
that things aren't ideal.
But usually that's just a little
bit of a tweak on the
actual ideal algorithm.
And for many programs, the
ideal algorithm you don't
actually have to tweak
at all to get a
good practical algorithm.
So here is just saying the
cache should be tall.
Now, just as an example, if we
look at the machines that
we're using, the cache-line
length is 64 bytes.
The L1 cache size
is 32 kilobytes.
And of course, for L1 it's is
32 kilobytes and for L2 and
L3, it's even bigger.
It's even taller.
Because they also
have 64k line.
So this is a fairly reasonable
assumption to make, that you
have more lines in your cache
then essentially the length,
the number of items you can
put on a cache line.
Now why is this an important
assumption?
So what's wrong with
short caches?
So we're going to look at,
surprise, surprise, matrix
multiplication.
Which, by the end of this class
you will learn more
algorithms than matrix
multiplication.
But it is a good one to
illustrate things.
So the idea here is, suppose
that you have an
n by n matrix here.
And you don't have this
tall-cache assumption.
So where your cache is short.
You have a lot of bytes in a
line, but very few lines.
Then even if the size of
your matrix fits, in
principle, in the cache.
In other words, n squared is
less than m by more than a
constant amount.
So you'd say, Oh gee, that
ought to fit in.
If you have a short cache it
doesn't necessarily fit in
because your length n here is
going to be shorter than the
number of bytes on a line.
However, if you have a tall
cache, it's always the case
that if the matrix size is
smaller than the cache size by
a certain amount, then the
matrix will fit in the cache.
OK, question?
AUDIENCE: Why wouldn't
you fit more than one
row per cache line?
PROFESSOR: Well the issue is you
may not have control over
the way this is laid out.
So, for example, if this is
row-major order, and this is a
submatrix of a much bigger
matrix, then you may not have
the freedom to be using these.
But if you have the tall-cache
assumption, then any section
you pull out is going to fit.
As long as the data fits
mathematically in the cache,
it will fit practically in
the cache if you have the
tall-cache assumption.
Whereas if it's short, you
basically end up with the
cache lines being long and you
not having any flexibility as
to where the data goes.
So this is sort of a--
So any questions about
that before we get
into the use of this?
We're going to see the use of
this and where it comes up.
So one of the things is that,
if it does fit in, then it
takes, at most, size of the
matrix divided by the cache
line size misses
to load it in.
So this is linear time
in the cache world.
Linear time says, you should
only take one cache fault for
every line of cache.
And so that's what you'll have
here if you have a tall cache.
You'll have n squared over b
cache misses to load in n
square data.
And that's good.
OK, good.
So let's take on the problem
of multiplying matrices.
We're going to look at square
matrices because they're
easier to think about than
rectangular ones.
But almost everything I say
today will relate to
rectangular matrices as well.
And it we'll generalize
beyond matrices as
we'll see next time.
So here's a typical code for
multiplying matrices.
It's not the most efficient code
in the world, but it's
good enough to illustrate
what I want to show you.
So the first thing is, what is
the work of this algorithm?
This is, by the way, the
softball question.
What's the work?
So the work, remember, is just
if you're analyzing it just
like processor forget about
caches and so forth.
AUDIENCE: n cubed.
PROFESSOR: n cubed, right.
Because there's a triply nested
loop going up to n and
you're doing constant
work in the middle.
So it's n times n times 1.
n cubed work.
That was easy.
Now let's analyze caches.
So we're going to look
at row major.
I'm only going to illustrate the
cache lines on this side
because B is where all
the action is.
So we're going to analyze two
cases when the matrix doesn't
fit in the cache.
If the matrix fits in the cache,
then there's nothing to
analyze, at some level.
So we're going to look at the
cases where the matrix doesn't
fit in the cache.
And the first one is going to be
when the side of the matrix
is bigger than m over b.
So remember, m over b is the
height of our cache, the
number of lines in our cache.
So let's assume for this, now
I have a choice of assuming
optimal omniscient replacement
or assuming LRU.
Since I want to show this is
bad, I'm going to assume LRU.
Could somebody please close
the back door there?
Because it's we're getting some
noise in from out there.
Thank you.
So let's assume LRU.
So what happens in the code is
basically I go across a row of
A, while I go down a column of
B. And now if I'm using LRU,
what's happening?
I read in this cache
block and this one,
then this one et cetera.
And if n is bigger than M/B and
I'm using least recently
used, by the time I get down
to the bottom here, what's
happened the first cache line?
First cache block?
It's out of there.
It's out of there
if I used LRU.
So therefore, what happens
is I took a miss on
every one of those.
And then when I go to the second
one, I take a miss on
every one again.
And so as I keep going through,
every access to B
causes a miss throughout the
whole accessing of B. Now go
on to the second row A and I
had the same thing repeats.
So therefore, the number of
cache misses is order n cubed
since we miss on matrix
B on every access.
OK, question.
AUDIENCE: I know that
you said it's e.
Does B push out due to conflict
misses or capacity misses?
PROFESSOR: So in this case
they're capacity misses that
we're talking about here.
So there's no conflict misses in
a fully associative cache.
Conflict misses occurs because
of direct mapping.
So there's no conflict misses
in what I'm going to be
talking about today.
That is an extra concern that
you have for real caches, not
a concern when you have a
fully associative cache.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
n needs to be bigger than B?
PROFESSOR: So the number of
lines to fit in my cache is m
over b, right?
AUDIENCE: So can't you put
multiple units of data--
PROFESSOR: Well there are
multiple units of data.
But notice this is row major,
what's stored here
is B11, B12, B13.
That's stored here.
The way I'm going through the
access, I'm going down the
columns of B. So by the time
to get up to the top again,
that cache block is
no longer there.
And so when I access B12,
assuming indexing from one or
whatever, this block is
no longer in cache.
Because LRU would say, somewhere
along here I hit the
limit of my size of cache,
let's say around here.
Then when this one goes
in, that one goes out.
When the next one goes in, the
next one goes out et cetera
using the least recently
used replacement.
So my--
AUDIENCE: Spatial locality.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
You don't have any spatial
locality here.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering
why they can't hold units.
I guess this is the question,
why can't they hold multiple
addresses per cache line.
So why is it even pushed out?
It's being pushed out
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] one per cache
line, right?
PROFESSOR: No, so it's getting
pushed out because the cache
can hold M/B blocks, right?
So once it's accessed m over b
blocks, if I want to access
anything else, something
has to go out.
It's a capacity issue.
I access m over b blocks,
something has to go out.
LRU says, the latest thing that
I accessed, well that was
the first one, gets
knocked out.
So what happens is every
one causes a miss.
Even though I may access that
very nearby in the future, it
doesn't take advantage
of that.
Because LRU says knock it out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Is it row major
that's the confusion?
This is the way we've been
dealing with are matrices.
So in row major, there's
a good--
that's nice, there's
no chalk here.
Oh, there's a big one
there, great.
Yeah, so here's B. So the order
that B is stored is like
this in memory.
So basically we're storing these
elements in this order.
So it's a linear block
of memory, right?
And it's being stored row
by row as we go through.
So actually if I do it like
this, let me do this
a little bit more.
So the idea is that the first
element is going to be here,
and then we get up to n minus 1,
and then we get to n minus
2 is stored here.
n plus 1, n plus
2, 2n minus 1.
So that's the order that
they're stored
in linear and memory.
Now these guys will all be on
the same cache line if it's in
row-major storage.
So when I'm accessing B, I'm
going and I'm accessing zero,
then I'm accessing the
thing at location n.
And I'm going down like this.
At some point here I reach
the limit of my cache.
This is M/B. Notice it's
a different B--
script B verses--
so when I get to m over b.
Now all these things
are sitting in
cache, that's great.
However, now I go to one more,
and it says OK, all those
things are sitting in cache,
which one do I kick out?
And the answer is the least
recently used one.
That's this guy goes out.
AUDIENCE: Do you only use one
element per cache link?
PROFESSOR: And I've only used
one element from each cache
line at this point.
Then I go to the next one and it
knocks out the second one.
By the time I get to the bottom
and then I go up to the
top to access 1 here,
it's not in cache.
And so it repeats the same
process, missing
every single time.
We have a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,so my question
is why does the cache know
where each row is?
To us, we draw the matrix,
but the computer
doesn't know it's a matrix.
To the computer, its a linear
array of numbers.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So why would it load
the first couple elements in
the first row, and the second
column is an extended row the
second time.
PROFESSOR: So the cache blocks
are determined by the locality
and memory.
AUDIENCE: So my assumption
would be the first
cache line for say--
PROFESSOR: Let's say
0 through 3.
AUDIENCE: So yeah,
PROFESSOR: Let's say we have
four items on that cache line.
AUDIENCE: 4 to 6.
PROFESSOR: The next one the
hold 4 to 7, I think.
AUDIENCE: 4 to 7, yeah.
So that is a--
PROFESSOR: So that would
be the next one, right?
4 to 7.
AUDIENCE: When you
get cache line.
You are not using the
fully cache line.
There is no spatial locale.
You are using one from
the cache line.
PROFESSOR: So this code
is using this one
and then this one.
It's not using the rest.
So it's not very
efficient code.
AUDIENCE: So the cache line
is holding the 0 to 3
and the 4 to 7.
[INAUDIBLE]
n plus 2 just reading--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Right.
And those are fixed.
So if you just a dice up memory
in our machine into 64
byte sizes, those are the things
that come in together
whenever you access anything
on that line.
AUDIENCE: And on this particular
axis, you never
actually get the 4
to the 7 in the--
PROFESSOR: Well we
eventually do.
Until we get there,
yes, that's right.
Until we get there.
Now, of course, we're also
accessing A and C, but turns
out to this analysis it
sufficient to show that we're
getting n cubed misses just on
the matrix B. In order to say
hey, we've got a lot
of misses here.
So this was the case where
n was bigger than
the size of a cache.
So the situation is a little
bit different if n is large
but still actually less
than m over b.
So in this case, we suppose it
n squared is bigger than m.
So the matrix doesn't
fit in memory.
So that's what this part of the
equation is, m to the 1/2
less than n is the same as n
squared is bigger than memory.
So we still don't fit in memory,
but in fact it's less
than some constant
times m over b.
And now let's look at the
difference with what happens
with the caches as we go
through the algorithm.
So we essentially do
the same thing.
Once again, we're going
to assume LRU.
And so what happens is we're
going to go down
a single row there.
But now, notice that by the time
I get down to the bottom,
basically I've accessed fewer
than some constant times m
over b locations.
And so nothing has gotten
kicked out yet.
So when I go back to the top for
the next access to B, all
these things are still
in memory.
So I don't take a cache fall,
a cache miss in those cases.
And so we keep going through.
And basically this is much
better because we're actually
getting to take advantage
of the spatial locality.
So this algorithm
takes advantage
of the spatial locality.
If n is really big it doesn't,
but if n is just kind of big,
then it does.
And then if n is small enough,
of course, it all fits in
cache and there's no misses
other than those needed to
bring it in once.
And then the same thing happens
once you go through
the next one.
So in this case, what's
happening is we have n squared
over b misses per run through
the matrix B, and then we have
n times that we go through.
Once for every row of A. So the
total then is n cubed over
b the cache block size.
So depending upon the size, we
can analyze with this, that
this is better because we get
a factor of B improvement.
But it's still not particularly
good.
And it only works, of course,
if my side of my matrix fits
in the number of lines
of cache that I have.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain in--
I don't understand why you
have n cubed over b?
PROFESSOR: OK, so we're going
through this matrix n times.
And for each one of those,
we're running
through this thing.
So this thing basically, I get
to go b times through, because
all these things are going to be
in memory when I come back
to do them again.
And so it's only once every B
columns that I take a miss.
I take a miss and then I get to
the other b minus 1 access
is that I get cache hit.
And so the total here is
then n squared over b.
So therefore a total
of n cubed over b.
So even this is not very good
compared to what we can
actually do if we exploit
the cache well.
So let's go on and
take a look.
We saw this before.
Let's use tiling.
So the idea of tiling is to say,
let's break our matrix
into blocks of s times s size.
And essentially what we do is we
treat our big matrix as if
we're doing block matrix
multiplications of things of
size s by s.
So the inner loop here is doing
essentially the matrix
multiplication.
It's actually matrix
multiply and add.
The inner three loops are just
doing ordinary matrix
multiplication, but on
s-sized matrices.
And the outer loop is jumping
over matrix by matrix for each
of those doing a matrix
multiply as
its elemental piece.
So this is the tiling solution
that you've seen before.
We can analyze it in
this model to see,
is this a good solution.
So everybody clear on
what the code does?
So it's a lot of four
loops, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There should be
less than n somewhere?
There's like an and something.
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
That must have happened
when I coped it.
That should be j less
than n here.
It should just follow
this pattern.
i less than n, k less than
n, that should be
j less than n there.
Good catch.
I did execute this.
That must have happened
when I was editing.
So here's the analysis
of work.
So what's going on
in the work?
So here we have, basically the
outer loop is going n over s
times, each loop.
So there's cube there times the
inner loops here which are
going each s times.
So times s cubed.
Multiply that through,
n cubed operations.
That's kind of what
you'd expect.
What about cache misses?
So the whole idea here is that
s becomes a tuning parameter.
And whether we choose s well or
poorly influences how well
this algorithm works.
So the idea here is we want tune
s so that the submatrices
just fit into cache.
So in this case, if I want a
matrix to fit into cache, I
want to be about the size
of the square root
of the cache size.
And this is where we're going
to use the tall-cache
assumption now.
Because I want to say, it fits
in cache, therefore I can just
assume it all fits in cache.
It's not like the size fits but
the actual data doesn't,
which is what happens with
the short cache.
So the tall-cache assumption
implies that when I'm
executing one of these inner
loops, what's happening?
When I'm executing one of these
linear loops, all of the
matrices are going
to fit in cache.
So all I have is my
cold misses, if
any, on that submatrix.
And how many cold misses
can I have?
Well the size of the matrix is
s squared and I get to bring
in b bytes of the matrix
each time.
So I get s squared over b
misses per submatrix.
So that was a little bit fast,
but I just want to make sure--
it's at one level
straightforward, and the other
level it's a little bit fast.
So the point is that the inner
three loops I can analyze if I
know that s is fitting
in cache.
The inner three loops I can
analyze by saying, look it's s
squared data.
Once I get the data in cache,
if I'm using an optimal
replacement, then it's going
to stay in there.
And so it will cost me s squared
over b misses to bring
that matrix in for each
of the three matrices.
But once it's in there, I can
keep going over and over it as
the algorithm does.
I don't get any cache misses.
Because those all fitting
in the cache.
Question?
Everybody with me?
OK.
So then I basically have
the outer three loops.
And here I don't make any
assumptions whatsoever.
There's n over s iterations
for each loop.
And there's three loops.
So that's n over s cubed.
And then the cost of the misses
in the inner loop is s
squared over b.
And that gives me n cubed over
bm to the 1/2 if you plug in s
being m to the 1/2.
So this is radically better
because m is usually big.
Especially for a higher level
cache, for an L2 or an L3. m
is really big.
What was the value we had before
for the best case for
the other algorithm when it
didn't fit in matrix?
It was n cubed over b.
b is like 64 bytes.
m is like the small L1 cache
is 32 kilobytes.
So you get to square root
the 32 kilobytes.
What's that?
So that's 32 kilobytes
is 2 to the 15th.
So it's 2 to the 7.5.
2 to the 7 is 128.
So it's somewhere between
128 and 256.
So if we said 128, I've got a 64
and a 128 multiplier there.
Much, much better in terms
of calculating.
In fact, this is such that if we
tune this properly and then
we say, well what was the cost
of the cache misses here,
you're not going to see the cost
of the cache misses when
you do your performance
analysis.
It's all going to be the work.
Because the work is
still n cubed.
The work is still n cubed,
but now the misses are so
infrequent, because we're
only getting one every--
on the order of 64 times 128,
which is 2 to the 6th times 2
to the 7th is 2 to
the 13th is 8K.
Every 8,000 or so accesses
there's a constant factor in
there or whatever, but every
8,000 or so accesses we're
getting a cache miss.
Uh, too bad.
If it's L1, that cost is four
cycles rather than one.
Or that cost us 10 cycles if I
had to go to L2 rather than
one, or whatever.
So is to the point is, that's
a great multiplier to have.
So this is a really
good algorithm.
And in fact, this is the optimal
behavior you can get
for matrix multiplication.
Hong and Kung proved back in
1981 that this particular
strategy and this bound was
the best you could do for
matrix multiplication.
So that's great.
I want you to remember this
number because we're going to
come back to it.
So remember it's b times n to
the 1/2, b times square root
of m in the denominator.
Now there's one hitch
in this story.
And that is, what do I
have to do for this
algorithm to work well?
It says right up there
on the slide.
Tune s.
I've got to tune s.
How do I do that?
How do I tune s?
How would you suggest
we tune s?
AUDIENCE: Just run a
binary [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, do binary
search on s to find out what's
the best value for s.
Good strategy.
What if we guess wrong?
What happens if, say, we tune
s, we get some value for it.
Let's say the value is 100.
So we've turned it.
We find 100 is our best value.
We run it on our workstation,
and somebody else has another
job running.
What happens then?
That other job starts sharing
part of that cache.
So the effective cache size is
going to be smaller than what
we turned it for.
And what's going to happen?
What's going to happen
in that case?
If I've tuned in for a given
size and then I actually have
to run with something that's
effectively a smaller cache,
does it matter or
doesn't matter?
AUDIENCE: Is it still tall?
PROFESSOR: Still tall.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So if you imagine
this fit exactly into cache,
and now I only have
half that amount.
Then the assumption that these
three inner loops is running
with only s squared over b
misses is going to be totally
out the window.
In fact, it's going to be just
like the case of the first
algorithm, the naive algorithm
that I gave.
Because the size of matrix that
I'm feeding it, s by s,
isn't fitting in the cache.
And so rather than it being s
squared over b accesses, it's
going to be much bigger.
I'm going to end up with
essentially s cubed accesses
if the cache, in fact,
gets enough smaller.
It's also one thing you have to
put in there is what I like
to call voodoo.
Whenever you have a program and
you've got some parameters
that, oh good we've got these
parameters we get to tweak to
make it go better.
I call those voodoo
parameters.
Because typically setting them
is not straightforward.
Now there are different
strategies.
One, as you say, is to do binary
search by doing it.
There are some programs, in
fact, which when you start
them up you call an
initialization routine.
And what they will do is
automatically check to see
what size is my cache and what's
the best size should I
do something on and then use
that when you actually run it
later in the program.
So it does an automatic
adaptation
automatically when you start.
But the more parameters
you get, the more
troublesome it becomes.
So let's take a look.
For example, suppose we have a
two-level cache rather than a
one-level cache.
Now I need to have something
that I tune in for L1 and
something that I tune for L2.
So it turns out that if I want
to optimize s and t, I can't
do it in more with binary search
because I have two
parameters.
And binary search won't suffice
for figuring out
what's the best combination
of s and t.
And generally multidimensional
searches are much harder than
one-dimensional searches
for optimizing.
Moreover, here's what
the code looks like.
So now I've got, how
many four loops?
1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9 nested
for loops.
So you can see the voodoo
is starting to
make this stuff run.
You really have to be a magician
to tune these things
appropriately.
I mean, if you can can
do it that's great.
But if you don't do it, OK.
So now what about three
levels of cache?
So now we need three
tuning parameters.
Here s, t and u, we have
12 nested four loops.
I didn't have the heart to
actually write out the code
for the 12 nested for loops.
That just seemed overhead.
But our new halo machines,
they have
three levels of caches.
So let's tune for all the
levels of caches.
And as we mentioned, in a
multi-program environment, you
don't actually know what the
cache size is, what other
programs are running.
So it's really easy to mistune
these parameters.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] don't
you have a problem because
you're running the program for
a particular n, and you don't
necessarily know whether your
program is going to run faster
or slower--
PROFESSOR: Well what you're
usually doing, is you're
tuning for s not n, right?
So you're assuming--
AUDIENCE: No, no
a particular n.
PROFESSOR: But the tuning of
this is only dependent on s.
It doesn't depend on n.
So if you run it for a
sufficiently large n, I think
it's reasonable to assume that
the s you get would be a good
s for any large n.
Because the real question is,
what's fitting in cache?
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: How long does it
take to fill up the cache
relative to the context
each time?
PROFESSOR: Generally you can
do it pretty quickly.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So why does it matter if your
have multiple users, if you
can fill it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No because, he
may not be using all
of the cache, right?
So when you come back, you're
going to have it polluted with
a certain amount of stuff.
I think it's a good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so anyway, so
this is the-- yeah question.
AUDIENCE: So if n is really
large, is it possible that the
second row of the matrix
never loaded?
PROFESSOR: If n is
really large--
AUDIENCE: Because n is
really large, right?
Just the first row of
the matrix will
fill up all the caches.
PROFESSOR: It's LRU and in B
you're going down this way.
You're accessing things
going down.
OK, good.
So let's look at a solution
to these alternatives.
What I want to in particular
take a look at is recursive
matrix multiplication.
So the idea is you can do
divide and conquer on
multiplying matrices because if
I divide each of these into
four pieces, then essentially
I have 8 multiply adds of n
over 2 by n over 2 matrices.
Because I basically do these
eight multiplies each going
into the correct result.
So multiply A11 B11 and
add it into C11.
Multiply A12 B21 add it
into C11 and so forth.
So I can basically do
divide and conquer.
And then each of those I
recursively divide and conquer.
So what's the intuition
by why this might a
good scheme to use?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, we're not
going to do parallel yet.
Just why is this going to
use the cache well?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah eventually I get
down to a size where the
matrix that I'm working on fits
into cache, and then all
the rest of the operations
I do are all
going to be cache hits.
It is taking something and it
it's doing what the tiling is
doing but doing it blindly.
So let's take a look.
Here's the recursive code.
So here I have the base case if
n is 1, I basically have a
one by one matrix and I
just simply update c,
with a times b.
And otherwise what I do, is
I'm going to do this by
computing offsets.
So generally when you're
dealing with matrices,
especially if you want fast
code, I usually don't rely on
two-dimensional addressing, but
rather do the addressing
myself and rely on the
compiler to do common
subexpression elimination.
So, for example, here
what I'm going to do
is compute the offsets.
So here's how I do it.
So first of all, in practice
what you do, is you don't go
down to n equals 1.
You have some cutoff.
Maybe n is 8 or something.
And at that point you go into
a specialized routine that
does a really good
8 by 8 multiply.
And the reason for that is you
don't want to have the
function call overheads.
This function call is expensive
to do two floating
point operations here.
So you'd like to have a function
call and then do 100
floating point operations
or something.
So that you get a
better balance.
Do people understand that?
So normally to write recursive
codes you want a
course in the recursion.
Make it so you're not going
all go the into way
down to n equals 1.
But rather are stopping short
and then doing something that
doesn't involve a lot of
overhead in the base case of
your recursion.
But here I'll explain it as
if we went all the way
down to n equals 1.
So then what we do is, if this
is a submatrix, which is
basically what I'm
showing here.
We have an n by n submatrix.
And it's being pulled out on a
matrix of size row size, of
width row size.
So what I can do is, if I want
to know where the elements of
the beginning of matrices are,
well the first one is exactly
the same place that the
input matrix is.
The second one is basically I
have to add n over 2 to the
location in the array.
The third one here, 21, I have
to basically add n over 2 rows
to get the starting point
of that matrix.
And for the last one I have to
add n over 2 and n over 2 rows
and n over 2 plus 1 rows
to get to that point.
So I compute those and now I can
recursively multiply with
sizes of n over 2 and perform
the program recursively.
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: So you said
it rightly.
You're blindly dividing the
matrix up til you get
something to fit the cache.
So essentially--
PROFESSOR: Well and
you're continuing.
The algorithm is completely
blind all the way
down to n equals 1.
AUDIENCE: This could never be
better if the other one-- your
computer's version
is well-tuned.
Because the applications are
the same, but this one you
have all the overhead from
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Could be.
AUDIENCE: At the end, you
still need to make a
multiplication and then go back
and look at all of the--
PROFESSOR: Could be.
So let's discuss that later at
the end when we talk about the
differences between
the algorithms.
Let's at this point, just try to
understand what's going on
in the algorithm.
Question--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: n over 2 times
row size plus--
plus n over 2.
It should be row size plus 1.
You're right.
Good, bug.
Should be n over 2 times
row size plus 1.
So let's analyze the work
assuming the code
actually did work.
So the work we can write
a recurrence for.
So here we have the
work to solve an
n by n matrix problem.
Well if n is 1, then it's
just order one work--
constant amount of work.
But if n is bigger than 1,
then I'm solving eight
problems of size n over 2, plus
doing a constant amount
of work to divide
all those up.
So everybody understand where
I get this recurrence?
Now normally, as you know, when
you do algorithmic work,
we usually omit this first line
because we assume a base
case of constant if it's one.
I'm actually going to keep it.
And the reason is because when
we do caching the basic cases
are important.
So everybody understand where
this recurrence came from?
So I can use the master theorem
or something like that
to solve this.
In which case the answer
for this is what?
Those of you who
have the master
theorem in your hip pocket.
What's the solution of
this recurrence?
People remember?
Who's has heard of the
master theorem?
I thought that was kind of a
prerequisite or something of
this class, right?
So you might want to brush up on
the master theorem for the
quiz next week.
So basically it's a n over
b, so it's n to the
log base 2 of 8.
So that's n cubed, n to
the log base 2 of 8
is n to the n cubed.
And that's bigger than the order
one here, so the answer
is order n cubed.
Which is a relief, right?
Because if weren't order n cubed
we would be doing a lot
more work than one of the
looping algorithms.
However, let's actually go
through and understand where
that n cubed comes from.
And to do that I'm going to
use the technique of a
recursive tree, which I think
all of you have seen.
But let me go through it slowly
here to make sure,
because we're going to do it
again when we do cache misses
and it's going to be
more complicated.
So here's the idea.
I write down the left hand side
the recurrence, w of n.
And now what I do is
I substitute, and I
draw it out as a tree.
I have eight problems
of size n over 2.
So what I do is I replace that
with the thing that's on the
right hand side, I've dropped
the theta here, but basically
put just a constant one here.
Because I'll take into account
the thetas at the end.
So I have a one here, and
then I have, loops
that should be a w.
Should be w n over 2.
That's a bug there.
And then I replace
each of those.
OK, wn over 2, sorry that
should be wn over 4.
Ah, more bugs.
I'll fix them up on
after lecture.
So this should be
w of n over 4.
And we go all the way down to
the bottom to where I hit the
base case of theta 1.
So I built out this big tree
that represents, if you think
about it, that's exactly what
the algorithm is going to do.
It's going to walk this
tree doing the work.
And what I've just simply put up
here is to work it does at
every level.
So the first thing we want to
do is figure out what's the
height of this tree.
Can somebody tell me what the
height of the tree is?
It is a log n.
What's the base?
Log base 2 of n, base because
at every level if I hadn't
made a mistake here, I'm
actually having the argument.
So I'm having the argument
at each level.
So the height is log
base 2 of n.
So LG is notation
for log base 2.
So if I have log base 2 of n,
I can count how many leaves
there are to this tree.
So how many leaves are there?
Well I'm branching a factor
of eight at every level.
And if I'm going log base 2
levels, the number of leaves
is 8 to the log base 2.
So 8 to the log base 2 of n.
And then with a little bit of
algebraic magic that turns out
that's the same as n to
the log base 2 of 8.
And that is equal to n cubed.
So I end up with
n cubed leaves.
Now let's add up all the
work that's in here.
So what I do is I add
across the rows.
So the top level I've
got work of one.
The next level I
work of eight.
The next I have work of 64.
Do people see the pattern?
The work is growing how?
Geometrically.
And at this level I know that
if I add up all the leaves
I've got work of n cubed.
Because I've got n cubed
leaves, each of
them taking a constant.
And so this is geometrically
increasing, which means that
it's all born in the leaves.
So the total work is
order n cubed.
And that's nice.
It's the same work is the
looping versions.
Because we don't want
to increase that.
Questions?
Because now we're going to do
cache misses and it's going to
get hairy, not too hairy,
but hairier.
So here we're going
to cache misses.
So the first thing is coming
up with a recurrence.
And this is probably the hardest
part, except for the
other hard part which is
solving the recurrence.
So here what we're doing is, we
have the same thing is that
I'm solving eight problems of
size n over 2 and to do the
work in here.
I'm taking basically order
one cache misses.
However I do, those
things work out.
Plus the cache misses
I have in there.
But then at some point, when I'm
claiming is that I'm going
to bottom out the
recursion early.
Not when I get to n equals 1,
but in fact when n squared is
less than some constant
times the cache size.
For some sufficiently
small concept.
And what I claim, at that point,
is that the number of
cache misses I'm going to take
at that point, I can just,
without doing any more recursive
stuff, I can just
say it's n squared over b.
So where does that come from?
So this basically comes from
the tall-cache assumption.
So the idea is that when n
squared is less than a
constant times the size of your
cache, constant times the
size of m, then that means
that this fits into--
the n by n matrices
fit within m.
I've got three of them.
I've got C, A and B. So that's
where I need a constant here.
So they're all going
to fit in memory.
And so if I look at it, all I
have to do is count up the
cold misses for bringing in
those submatrices at the time
that n hits this threshold here
of some constant times m.
And to bring in those matrices
is only going to cost me n
squared over b cache misses.
And once I've done that, all of
the rest of the recursion
that's going on down below is
all operating out of cache.
It's not taking any misses
if I have an
optimal replacement algorithm.
it's not taking any more misses
as I get further down.
Questions about this part
of the recurrence here?
So people with me?
So when I get down to something
of size n squared,
where the submatrix is size n
squared, the point is that
I'll bring in the entire
submatrix.
But all the stuff that I have to
do in there is never going
to get kicked out, because
it's small
enough that it all fits.
And an optimal algorithm for
replacement is going to make
sure that stuff stays in there,
because there's plenty
of room in the cache
at that point.
There's room for three matrices
in the cache and a
couple of other variables that
I might need and that's
basically it.
Any questions about that?
So let's then solve
this recurrence.
So we're going to go about it
very much the same way.
We make draw a recursion tree.
So those of you are rusty in
drawing recursion trees, I can
promise you there will be a
recursion tree on the quiz
next Thursday.
I think I can promise that.
Can I promise that?
Yeah, OK I can promise that.
The way I like to do it, by the
way, is not to try to just
brought out all at once.
In my own notes when I do this I
always draw it step by step.
I copy over and just
do a step by step.
You might think that
that's extensive.
Gee, why do I have to draw
every one along the way?
Well the answer is, it's
a geometric process.
All the ones going up to the
last one are a small amount of
the work to draw out
the last one.
And they help you get it
correct the first time.
So let me encourage you
to draw out the tree
iteration by iteration.
Here I'm going to just
do replacement.
So what we do is we replace with
the right hand side to do
the recursion.
And replace that.
And once again I made the bug,
that should be in over 8.
Sorry, n over 4 here.
n over 4.
And then we keep going down
until I get to the base case,
which is this case here.
Now comes the first hard part.
How tall is this tree?
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
square root of n over b.
You want n squared to be
cm, not [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So here's the thing,
let's discuss, first of
all, why this is what it is.
So at the point where n squared
is less than cm, that
says that it's going to cost
us n squared over b.
But n squared is just less than
cm, so therefore, this is
effectively m over b.
Good question.
So everybody see that?
So when I get down to the
bottom, it's basically costing
me something that's about the
number of lines I have in my
cache, number of misses
to fill things up.
The tricky thing is,
what's the height?
Because this is crucial to
getting this kind of
calculation right.
So what is the height
of this tree?
So I'm having every time.
So one way to think about it is,
it's going to be log bas 2
of n, just as before, minus the
height of the tree that is
hidden here that I didn't have
to actually go into because
there are no cache
misses in it.
So that's going to occur when
n is approximately m, cm,
sorry when n is approximately
square root of cm.
So I end up with log of
n minus 1/2 log of cm.
That's the height here.
Because the height at this
point of the tree that's
missing because they're no
cache, I don't have to account
for any cache misses in there,
is log of cm to the one half,
based on this.
Does that follow
for everybody?
People comfortable?
Yeah?
OK, good.
So now what do we do?
We count up how many
leaves there are.
So the number of leaves is 8,
because I have a branching
factor of 8, 2 whatever
the height is.
Log n minus 1/2 log of cm.
And then if I do my matrix
magic, well that part is n
cubed, the minus becomes a
divide, and now 8 to the 1/2
log of cm is the square
root of n cubed,
which is m to the 3/2.
Is that good?
The rest of it is very similar
to what we did before.
At every level I have a certain
number of things that
I'm adding up.
And on the bottom level, I take
the cost here, m over b,
and I multiply it by
a number of leaves.
When I do that I get, what?
I get n cubed over b
times m to the 1/2.
This is geometric.
So the answer is going, in this
case, just going to be
the sum of a constant factor
times the large thing.
And why does this
look familiar?
That was the optimal result
we got from tiling.
But where's the tuning
parameters?
No tuning parameters.
So that means that this analysis
that I did for one
level of caching, it applies
even if you have three levels
of caching.
At every level you're getting
near optimal cache behavior.
So it's got the same cache
misses as with tiling.
These are called cache-oblivious
algorithms.
Because the algorithm itself
has no tuning parameters
related to cache.
Unlike the tiling algorithm.
That's a cache-aware
algorithm.
The cache-oblivious algorithm
has no tuning parameters.
And if it's an efficient one.
So, by the way, our first
algorithm was
cache-oblivious as well.
The naive one.
It's just not efficient.
So in this case we have
an efficient one.
It's got no voodoo turning of
parameters, no explicit
knowledge of caches, and it
passively autotunes itself.
As it goes down when it fits
things into cache it fits them
and uses things locally.
And then it goes down and it
fits into the next level of
cache and uses things locally
and so forth.
It handles multi-level
caches automatically.
And it's good in
multi-programmed environments.
Because if you end up taking
away some of the cache it
doesn't matter.
It still will end up using
whatever cache is available
nearly as well as any other
program could use that cache.
So these are very good in
multi-programmed environments.
The best cache-oblivious matrix
multiplication, in fact
doesn't do an eight way split
as I described here.
That was easier to analyze
and so forth.
The best one that
I know work on
arbitrary rectangular matrix.
And what they do, is they
do binary splitting.
So you would take your matrix,
i times j, So if you take a
matrix, let's say it's
something like this.
So here we have i, k, k, j.
And you're going to get
something of shape.
i times j, right?
What it does, is it
takes whatever
is the largest dimension.
In this case k is the
largest dimension.
And it partitions either
one or both of the
matrices along k.
In this case, it doesn't
do that.
And then it recursively
solves the two
sub-rectangular problems.
And that ends up being a very,
very efficient fast code if
you code that up tightly.
So it does binary splitting
rather than--
and it's general.
And if you analyze this, it's
got the same behavior as the
eight way division.
It's just more efficient.
So questions?
We had a question about
now comparing
with the tiled algorithm.
Do you want to reprise
your question?
AUDIENCE: What I was
saying was, I guess
this answers my question.
If you were to tune the previous
algorithm properly,
and you're assuming it's
not in a multi-program
environment, the recursive one,
it will never be the one
that is locked.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So at some level
that's true, and at some level
it's not true.
So it is true in that if it's
cache-oblivious you can't take
advantage of all the corner
cases that you would might be
able to take advantage of
in a tiling algorithm.
So from that point of
view, that's true.
On the other hand, these
algorithms work even as you go
into paging and disks
and so forth.
And the interesting thing about
a disk, if you start
having a big problem that
doesn't fit in memory and, in
fact, is out of core as they
call it, and is paging to
disk, is that the disk sizes of
sectors that can be brought
efficiently off of
a disk, vary.
And the reason is because in
a disk, if you read a track
around the outside you can get
two or three times as much
data off the disk as a track
that you read near the inside.
So the head moves in and out
of the disk like this.
It's typically on a pivot
and pivots in and out.
If it's reading towards the
inside, you get blocks that
are small versus blocks
that are large.
This is effectively a
cache line size that
gets brought in.
And so the thing is that there
are actually programs in
which, when you run them on
disk, there is no fixed size
tuning parameter that beats
the cache-oblivious one.
So the cache-oblivious one will
beat every fixed-size
tuning parameters you put in.
Because you don't have any
control over where your file
got laid out on disk and how
much it's bringing in and how
much it isn't varies.
On the other hand, for in-core
thing, you're exactly right.
That, in principle, you could
tune it up more if you make it
more cache aware.
But then, of course, you suffer
from portability loss
and from, if you're in a
multi-programmed environment
and so forth.
So the answer is, that there
are situations where you're
doing some kind of embedded or
dedicated type of application,
you can take advantage of a lot
of things that you want.
There are other times
where you're doing a
multi-programmed environment,
or where you want to be able
to move something from one
platform to another without
having to re-engineer all of
the tuning and testing.
In which case it's better to
use the cache oblivious.
So as I mentioned, my view
of these things is that
performance is like
a currency.
It's a universal medium
of exchange.
So one place you might want
to pay a little bit of
performance is to make it so
it's very portable as for the
cache-oblivious stuff.
So you get nearly good
performance, but now I don't
have that headache
to worry about.
And then sometimes, in fact,
it actually does as well or
better than the one.
For matrix multiplication, the
best algorithms are the cache
oblivious ones that
I'm aware of.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
currency and all the different
currencies.
Single currency.
PROFESSOR: You want
a currency for--
so in fact the performance for
this is people who have
engineered it to take advantage
of exactly the cache
size, we can do just as well
with the cache oblivious one.
And particularly, if you think
about it, when you've got
three levels hierarchy,
you've got 12 loops.
And now you're going
to tune that.
It's hard to get it all right.
So next time we're going to see
a bunch of other examples
of cache-oblivious algorithms
that are optimal in terms of
their use of cache.
Of course, by the way, those
people who are familiar with
Strassen's algorithm, that's a
cache-oblivious algorithm.
Takes advantage the same
kind of thing.
And in fact you can analyze it
and come up with good bounds
on performance for Strassen's
algorithm just the same.
Just as we've done here.